hello everyone and welcome back to some
rapid action unleashes last game we
played it was a fun B4 variation against
the Knight C6 Sicilian and even though
we had a winning position in the end we
lost on time but uh yeah that's what
happens when you uh when when you're
down to your last seconds and your
opponent still has five minutes on the
clock so this game uh I will try to play
a little bit faster I thought um I
really thought that 10 minutes would be
more than enough time not just 10 me 10
my opponent 10 20 minutes would be
enough time to talk
and you know not just about a position
but maybe what happened yesterday in the
Chess World and stuff like that uh and
play but seems like uh yeah time really
flies when you're playing rapid which is
interesting because I've never actually
played rapid in my life uh so this
series that I'm doing now uh is the only
rapid that I've ever played but I'm I'm
actually enjoying it immensely so it's
it's completely different chest than
when I play uh bullet or or Blitz in
bullet or Blitz I'm pretty much just uh
uh pre-moving and watching something on
the other screen so it's not um really
something that can be considered chest
it's more a more of a Pastime activity
but yeah let's get back to the to the
game here so 10 minutes per player who
will be our opponents for this game we
get the black pieces and our opponent is
uh slow poison N1 from South Africa and
he goes for E4 so we're going to
continue with C5 uh I mentioned in the
previous video usually I go for the
scandin but um I will be playing C5 to
learn but also to maybe broaden my style
and he goes for C4 immediately it's sort
of the it's the marozi bind structure
and uh that he will be going for and
it's a very nice way for for white to
play without um pushing all that much
and you can always uh do this against
the Sicilian if black still hasn't
played Knight to F6 so okay uh we're
we're just going to go for our setup
here probably there's a move order that
is more efficient than just going for
the standard hyper accelerated Dragon
probably some A6 here but uh as I do not
know I'm just going to I'm just going to
put my pieces to Optimal squares uh like
Bishop like G6 Bishop G7 we're going to
play D6 Knight to C6 Knight to F6
castles and then we're going to uh we're
going to try and make the best of
it uh all right so our opponent uh
probably now contemplating D4 it's it's
always uh super enjoyable when when
someone plays early G6 because if you
play D4 he can uh take with the queen he
doesn't have to take with the Knight and
he will already be attacking the rook
and then if they're not used to playing
against early G6 then they will say okay
he will play Knight to F6 I'll play E5
and um yeah but he doesn't go he just
goes uh Knight to C3 okay uh we're going
to go Bishop here Bishop G7 continuing
our uh development okay so he he plays
it with the fian cat though uh okay uh I
I have no idea how how to actually play
this so uh I'm just going to see what it
does okay so it's a very interesting um
uh setup what he's doing Bishop here
will be incredibly strong he will Castle
King side he will play King to H1
probably and then he will wait with D4
but he will play Pawn to F4 so that's uh
that's what he's going for I have to
figure out how to play against
this uh as f for uh F4 E5 could be
somewhat annoying with Knight here so I
don't know if it works I'm going to play
Pawn to D6 instead of Pawn to
E5 uh just to be more
flexible okay and
uh yeah we're still going to play Knight
to F6 I'm not I'm not really sure about
Knight to D7 we're going to go Knight to
F6
uh yeah D4 if he plays D4 then we just
trade everything and it's perfectly fine
and it's the standard setup and he he
could even go for B3 and Bishop to B2
think care of both of his Bishops and
then it's just going to be uh long long
maneuvering game where he's going to try
to make his Bishops as strong as
possible before committing to anything
it's always a useful idea whenever you
play any any line of any
opening uh but yeah he will have to play
D3 or or D4 at some
point probably not now he's going to
play he okay so he has to consider does
does The Rook belong on E1 or does The
Rook belong on F1 to support F4 does he
want to play B3 and Bishop to B2 does he
want to play D3 doesn't want to play D4
does he want to play A3 and B4 does he
want to play H3 for some reason so I
mean sky is the limit here uh I couldn't
even try to guess what he will play
probably
D3 but I don't know maybe even
B3 or he will play something that I
haven't considered like Rook to B1 makes
also sense to move the Rook from this
diagonal like any move you you consider
here is a move like even even Queen C2
Queen to B3 seriously any move is a move
here that's what you uh get when we
haven't exchanged a single Pawn uh and a
single piece and it's already already
you know uh it's already the the middle
game yeah and he's really taking his
time uh Mr slow poison probably that's
where he gets his name from he's he he
takes it slow but you know then he then
he drains you with a superior position
hopefully that's not the case here okay
so he goes for H3 uh it's a it's a it's
a fine move uh one thing it does it
takes away the G4 Square from my knight
and another
thing uh it gives his King a bit more
room he can play King to H2 in the
future get off of this diagonal which is
relevant In the Sicilian and other lines
where this diagonal might open up uh and
he will have more support for executing
F4 so
okay uh I'm just going to allow it I
don't really have a way of not allowing
that and we're going to
Castle we're going to
Castle and
uh
yeah D4 for the moment yeah it's really
not a possibility since we can trade
everything and queen captures and then
we have all sorts of discoveries with
the Knight unfortunately not very useful
ones uh but it could come to come to
mind if the king is on H2 because then
after all of these trades on D4 imagine
Knight to G4 check picks up the queen of
course that will not happen it's merely
merely you know why if if he plays King
to H2 D D4 is no longer possible
uh so he will of course not do something
like that uh but yeah it's important to
calculate stuff like that so uh in the
game uh you don't have to and uh yeah
now again sky the limit here it's merely
a uh merely a matter of precision and uh
once again his name is slow poison so I
I I I could imagine something like Rook
to B1 being played here or even King H2
yeah really taking it slow Rook
Rook B1 D3 B4 or even Rook B1 A3 and B4
King H2 F4 later on F5 E5
whatever uh or or even something like
King H2 G4 Knight to G3 and then
maybe
yeah yeah I have no idea I do know that
I will have to as long as the since the
D file hasn't open up uh I will be
trying to get my Bishop to D7 and C6 if
I can get my Bishop to C6 with his
Bishop Fano on G2 then I'm going to be
super happy for the entire game and uh
don't even have to worry about my Rook
being on this
diagonal uh so if the position opens up
uh yeah but it's not easy to move yeah
like I go here it's uh not easy okay
since the C4 Pawn is for the moment
undefended we could actually play Bishop
to D7 Knight E5 with Tempo he has to
defend the pawn and then we shifted the
bishop over to C6 yeah I mean such a
thing would be
possible it would be more precise
probably yeah he goes for D3 yeah he's
really slowly poisoning Me Slowly
poisoning
me um yeah okay so now this is defended
and we don't have to worry about
anything like that so can we play Bishop
to D7 that's the real question can he
take advantage of this
somehow uh yeah maybe yeah maybe some
Bishop to D7 E5 because then I can't
capture with the Knight as the G7 B7
Pawn would hang so he he could mess up
my Pawn structure if I go is that is
that really a
problem I mean it could be it could be
but I don't think it is for the moment
this Pawn isn't all that uh relevant
here yeah I'm I'm kind of doubting he
will do that because he's taking so much
time
uh calculating everything and
preparing okay so Bishop
C5 makes
sense
uh yeah now the problem is if I go here
he can just play D4 and then captures
captures uh the Knight gains control of
the C6 Square so my Bishop will not be
joining C6 anytime
soon
uh but yeah now E5 sort of U I mean I I
lose all the flexibility here but uh
yeah it's
now it's now or
never now we're going to put the Knight
here and put the bishop on C6 and we I
don't think we have to yeah okay so he's
going for the standard setup
here uh as he should
we're going to play A6 first uh simply
to take away the B4 Square from the
knight uh okay so he wants to play A4
probably A5 grabbing more space that's
excellent ah yeah time to get that
Knight to but yeah we're still waiting
with
this yeah let's get a rook to
B8 uh it might look like a Tempo loss
because he will play A5 here uh not now
but he might at some point in the future
but if he doesn't The Rook will be
useful
here yeah let's get our Knight
here now probably some trades happen
maybe they don't still I mean because if
he captures I'm going to Capt kick away
his Knight and then he loses the pawn
here
so
yeah uh F4 yeah of course undermining
the kn KN makes sense he will never
capture there um yeah he can capture
here we don't care about that but we
could uh we could play Queen A5 the
queen no longer serves a purpose
here and
uh we no longer serves the purpose here
we're going after the pawn here uh if
takes we don't really care we're just
going to kick away the Knight and then
win the A4 Pawn we're now threatening to
win the A4 Pawn
uh not right away of course because he
will then have some nasty Rook to A1
action but uh B5 is now a move that he
will have to consider whatever he
plays uh I might even play Queen B4
first before executing B5 simply because
that Rook to A1 is always um possible
okay so he captures here we don't care
about that I I think we don't care about
that of course I could be wrong I've
been wrong many times in the previous
video that I've made on
uh on that crazy position in the B4
Sicilian so yeah okay so he takes
here uh why exactly because we attack
both
pieces is this some sort of a crazy
tactic that I'm
missing ah okay so he wants to capture
if I capture he wants to play Knight
here yeah and attack my queen and then
I'm going to attack his Queen and then
uh yeah that's smart it's very
smart uh but is it smart enough that is
the
question yeah
obviously this Pawn has to capture goes
without
saying yeah only move Knight B1 only
move otherwise he just resigns no it's
not the only move yeah he can also play
that oh yeah kind of makes more sense
yeah here we here we just sacrifice the
queen there's no uh other way to play
this we have to sacrifice the
queen yeah let's take Bishop as
well we attack the Rooks and we will
have sort of a closed position here with
not too many breakthroughs for him and
we will have the bishop pair we're
better on time
so I don't know I'm I'm quite confident
about this queen
sacrifice some of you say we shouldn't
call it a queen we shouldn't call it a
queen sacrifice because we gain material
for it but okay it's a it's a trade it's
a it's a trade for uh some minor pieces
and The Rook for for the queen okay so
we definitely have to capture
here and now we get this position
so we capture the rook and in the
end yeah this is what we get we have a
bishop and The Rook for a queen but we
like our position very
much okay so how do we how do we proceed
from
here maybe it was a bit overly ambitious
but uh what are you going to do so do I
keep everything intact he will play you
will play B4 B5 at some
point yeah the bishop is
strong
um yeah since he can't attack anything
at the
moment
oh this is actually the way to play it
F5 yeah just
go just go straight straight for opening
up the
position yeah now that uh now that uh
I've uh seen what I've done probably
there were better ideas but uh I know it
just seemed so it just seems so
right uh my idea is that I want to
somehow reach that base of the pawnin
and I even
though he it's kind of he's up material
because he has the queen but uh trading
down and trying to get that pawn and
maybe getting a past pass D Pawn seems
like the best long-term play for me yeah
he's going to go for B4 that's uh what
we already uh figured
out uh and now how do we play
this now we just trade
everything yeah we trade
everything he's going to play the bishop
captures
oh yeah serves me right serves me right
for opening up the the
king
okay not the end of the world though not
the end of the world though this Pawn
could now become very dangerous let's
take the Rook
first
huh let's take the Rook
first and Advance the pawn he will take
these pawns that's uh goes without
saying that goes without saying
he will play something like Queen to C7
put pressure on my rook and I will have
to move the Rook he will take the pawn
uh but what do we get in return do we
get anything in return we have to play
Rook
f8 for our Rook to be defended oh
yeah oh this is this is so
bad yeah let's do this have to give our
some breeding room for our
King
first and then we go here if he takes
the pawn if he doesn't he might just
push the pawn here yeah it's it could be
even
better yeah even better even better yeah
let's go here we have to
go we have to go
somehow
um yeah he controls the F3 Square yeah I
think I've overdone it I think I've
overdone
it
yeah there's no move for me here oh
that's that's so sad that's so
sad that is so yeah that's a useless
move useless
move that is a useless move yeah he's
going to give a
check yeah I don't think he needed
that uh but yeah he will play
it so now we're down to playing for
tricks
not the
best but yeah go here hoping for King
F3 no we're hoping for E2 he's probably
going to play Queen F3
now que here okay we go
here hopefully he takes if he doesn't we
push the
pawn ah again I'm forcing myself to pull
a rabbit out of a hat yeah okay now we
can't push the pawn that's so silly
that's so
silly now we have to give up the
pawn have to give up the
pawn now he's just better yeah let's go
here yeah that's nice that's nice always
nice
have to
defend yeah let's
take go
here okay so he he
wins check okay good
game good game let's see let's see his
uh his mating
technique what is the mating technique
okay bring the king in and Checkmate
that's the way to do it nicely done
nicely done Mr slow poison nicely done
all right so we're going to analyze this
slowly and uh in the previous video you
guys said that uh you would like to see
more of the analysis somehow so let me
just uh figure out a way how to or not
more of the analysis but you would just
like to see the bar uh but yeah okay the
bar is visible here just not for white
okay I see what you mean I see what you
mean okay so that was uh maybe me asking
too
much from the position let me just set
this
here sorry not
that
there we go all right so you will be
able to see the engine not all the way
but at least the evaluation and what the
engine gives uh so let's see this
uh let's see this brilliancy we we
attempted okay so this is all perfectly
fine this is a z0 okay Knight F6 sort of
not maybe the most precise but yeah okay
Knight gt7 should be played here H3 but
still this is all all very much drawish
uh yeah white white plus 0.6 which is
normal uh A4 okay sort of a question
mark but still those are all z0000 Z so
this is all perfectly fine yeah he
played that e captures on D4 uh Knight
D5 and I played captures okay
so uh yeah Queen to C5 with equality
Knight captures on on D4 on D5 a bit a
bit ambitious uh but still okay and F5
yeah F5 a losing move yeah B5 the move I
considered first is the way to go okay
but let's see if we if we had anything
here in this heavy heavy end game no no
no it was it was simply too strong for
him so while the queen sacrifice itself
was not a
problem uh following up on it definitely
was F5 here was just too ambitious for
one uh it allowed me to blunder a piece
as uh I opened up this diagonal and I
didn't even play King to h8 so yeah
definitely something to consider yeah B5
uh was the move I considered and I was
better on time so playing it quickly was
the way to go uh but you know you live
and you learn uh so yeah uh that's the
game hope you guys uh enjoyed it um it's
not the problem of the opening or
anything You' see I mean it's perfectly
fine you can play it uh just my my
reasoning in this game was the cause of
my downfall but yeah slow poison lived
up to his name he took it slow but then
in the end he was able to poison me uh
so yeah uh once again hope you guys
enjoyed it and I will see you soon uh
with the next one and by soon I mean
tomorrow as I'm making one of these per
day uh see you
soon